[Music]  looking to escape the heat and go  tropical  southwest wants to help starting this  sunday the airline adding non-stop  routes from las vegas to maui we spoke  to the vice president of southwest today  who says connecting hawaii to las vegas  or the ninth island as it's known  was a no-brainer they are also adding  flights to kona beginning september 7th  we're seeing a very strong demand to and  from las vegas so the  hawaii flights certainly give people an  opportunity both  to leave las vegas for vacation there's  also more options people to come  to las vegas and all these new cities  we've been adding  waterson also tells us the airline  prides itself on having low fares and  surviving the pandemic with no  staff layoffs southwest airlines began  offering non-stop flights from las vegas  to hawaii on june  6. brian